Fusion is a frustrating technology
because we all know that it'll work the
problem with Fusion is we haven't been
able to sustain a fusion reaction long
enough to generate electricity we've
known this for 30 to 50 years the joke
in the fusion energy community is at
fusion is always 30 years away and that
that remains the case today by any
foreseeable new developments but there
is research going on and one of these
days I would hope that somebody has a
breakthrough and that would truly be a
game changer because then we really
would very likely be able to have energy
so cheap that we wouldn't worry about
metering it but I don't think we can
count on that happening so then you look
at other alternatives like advanced
biofuels there clearly is great interest
in algae as a transportation fuel to
back out petroleum as well as some other
bio fuels biofuels are not entirely free
in the sense that you certainly want to
move towards developing biofuels
hopefully that don't compete with
foodstuffs and that's one of the big
problems with ethanol in our country and
corn but there are biofuels like algae
and others that don't compete with
feedstocks I've actually been a
developer I'm vice chairman of a company
based in Dubai that does biomass fuels
in Europe mainly because we get such
generous green tax credits it's
extremely attractive but there are
different crops that can be used we are
developing a proprietary technology that
is essentially like a bamboo type crop
we call it eat grass but it's
essentially a similar to a bamboo
virtually grows anywhere in the world
that's a temperate climate and like
bamboo grows very prolifically and very
cheaply one of the problems and biofuels
though is very expensive to transport
biofuels to their end use so when you
develop a biofuels plant you want as
much as possible to have your
biofuels plant as close to whatever end
juice it's going to be used for to cut
down on what are otherwise very
expensive transportation costs